en este vídeo vamos a hablar de soma tu
sensación imaginemos que alguien va
caminando por la calle y recibe todo
tipo de información del mundo que lo
rodea recibe diferentes tipos de
sensaciones también recibe diferentes
tipos de intensidades de estas
sensaciones como por ejemplo si afuera
hace mucho calor o no hace tanto calor
así que recibe información acerca de las
diferentes intensidades de las
sensaciones también recibe información
de la duración de una sensación por
ejemplo el momento en el que pone un pie
en el suelo y cuando levanta el pie del
suelo o si alguien pasa cerca de él y le
arroja una hamburguesa él percibe el
momento en el que la hamburguesa le
golpea y cuando deja de golpearlo así
que también recibe información sobre el
momento en el que ocurre algo
finalmente también recibe información
sobre qué parte de su cuerpo es donde se
origina la sensación por ejemplo si un
pájaro se le acerca y comienza a
picotear le el brazo el cerebro necesita
darse cuenta de que algo está sucediendo
en el brazo
así que también recibe información sobre
la ubicación
cuáles son los distintos tipos de
sensaciones que puede tener mientras
camina por la calle pues se necesita
información de la temperatura hace frío
afuera hace calor la sensación de la
temperatura se conoce como termo cepción
o termo recepción
también es necesaria la información
sobre la presión como la necesaria para
sentir que se ha puesto un pie en el
suelo o si alguien se le acerca y como
dijimos le lanza una hamburguesa él
necesita saber qué tan fuerte le golpeó
la hamburguesa la información sobre la
presión también se conoce como mecano
cepción o mecano recepción y qué más
necesita conocer necesita información
sobre el dolor por ejemplo si se le
acerca un pájaro y comienza a picotear
le el brazo le va a doler así que
necesita información acerca del dolor
esto se conoce como nocicepción y
finalmente él necesita conocer la
posición de su cuerpo en el espacio
conforme va caminando se encuentra cerca
de la banqueta está cerca de otra
persona necesita conocer la ubicación de
su cuerpo en el espacio esto se conoce
como propiocepción
estos son los diferentes tipos de
información que él necesita recibir del
mundo exterior mediante la superficie de
su cuerpo él también necesita conocer
algo de la intensidad de los diferentes
estímulos es bueno saber si hace mucho
calor afuera o si hace frío por lo que
la forma en la que la intensidad es
codificada en el cuerpo es mediante la
rapidez con la que se activan las
neuronas
hay varias neuronas que son sensibles a
la temperatura y otras neuronas que son
sensibles a la presión por lo que si
hace mucho frío afuera las neuronas
puede que no se activen mucho y solo se
activen pocas veces en el transcurso de
un minuto pero si hace mucho calor
afuera las neuronas se activarán muchas
veces de manera que la rapidez con la
que se activan es lo que determina la
intensidad otra información que
necesitamos registrar del entorno es el
momento si este pájaro bajará y fuera a
picotear a esta persona vuela
directamente hacia su brazo y lo picotea
y esta persona necesita saber el momento
en el que
inicia el picoteo y el momento en el que
este termina para que una neurona
codifique el momento hay tres formas
diferentes en las que puede hacerlo hay
una neurona que todo el tiempo que el
pájaro lo picotea va a activar
constantemente potenciales de acción
este tipo de neurona es no adaptativa y
es no adaptativa porque al ver los
potenciales de acción hay una cantidad
de espacio igual entre cada potencial de
acción sucesivo básicamente todo el
tiempo que se aplica el estímulo no hay
cambio en la tasa de activación otro
tipo de neurona va a comenzar a
activarse muy rápidamente por lo que
aquí hay muchos potenciales de acción
pero conforme pasa el tiempo irán más
despacio es decir que aumenta el espacio
entre los potenciales de acción conforme
pasa el tiempo pueden ver que al inicio
se activa rápidamente con el estímulo y
luego comienza a ir más despacio por lo
que el espacio aumenta esta neurona se
conoce como de adaptación lenta es de
adaptación lenta porque disminuye su
rapidez conforme se adapta al estímulo
tipo de neurona va a comenzar a
activarse muy rápidamente en cuanto
comienza el estímulo y luego dejará de
activarse después volverá a activarse
cuando termine el estímulo esta se
conoce como neurona de adaptación rápida
muy bien y cuál es la última pieza de
información que necesitamos obtener del
entorno si este pájaro comienza a
picotear lo él necesita saber que está
picoteando su brazo y tiene que haber
una forma en la que el cerebro se dé
cuenta de que es el brazo el que está
haciendo picoteado y no la pierna para
que el cerebro pueda hacer esto necesita
de los demás así dibujamos una figura
humana aquí está el torso un brazo otro
brazo y aquí están las piernas cada
parte del cuerpo está enervada por un
nervio en particular y ese nervio llega
al cerebro por lo que si un pájaro
picotea su brazo sabrá qué brazo está
haciendo picoteado el brazo enviará un
nervio al cerebro que le informa que el
brazo está siendo afectado muy bien
despejes
un poco ahora imaginemos que alguien
está volando por el cielo y se dirige
justo hacia este inocente transeúnte que
va caminando por la calle este hombre
tiene una capa roja en su espalda y las
personas le dicen superhéroe pero se
dirige justo hacia esta persona conforme
se acerca se va a estrellar con nuestro
caminante qué tipos de receptores se van
a activar en este caso la temperatura no
se va a registrar pues no habrá un
cambio en la temperatura la presión
definitivamente se va a activar porque
esta persona definitivamente va a
colisionar con este transeúnte que va a
sentir mucha presión por parte del
cuerpo del superhéroe dolor claro que sí
sentirá mucho dolor porque el superhéroe
está volando a 160 kilómetros por hora y
va a chocar con esta persona
directamente por lo que al impactar a
este espectador seguro sentirá algo de
dolor y probablemente será derribado
también por lo que sentirá un cambio en
la posición se van a activar estas tres
sensaciones diferentes
qué tan intensa es esta interacción pues
parece que es bastante intensa tenemos a
un superhéroe que choca con esta persona
por lo que todos estos tres tipos de
neuronas se van a activar de forma muy
rápida ahora veamos el momento sin duda
se activarán neuronas no adaptativas
porque todo el tiempo que el superhéroe
esté en contacto con este peatón se
estarán activando diferentes tipos de
neuronas para que su cerebro sepa que
algo está sucediendo
también habrá células de adaptación
rápida activándose en el instante en el
que el superhéroe toque al espectador y
en el momento en el que deje de estar en
contacto con él y también se activarán
células de adaptación lenta durante todo
el tiempo que el superhéroe y el
espectador estén en contacto y que hay
de la ubicación la cabeza del superhéroe
golpea directamente el torso de esta
persona por lo que se va a activar todo
el torso quizá también se activen los
nervios de los brazos por lo que
físicamente hay nervios que van a
enervar estas tres partes del cuerpo y
todos enviarán información al cerebro
para qué
sepa que hay presión dolor y cambio en
la posición aquí